as the american standard of living
plummets from spiking energy costs as
the dream dies the reaction of our
leaders to this catastrophe has been
highly revealing
a lot of them seem
what's the word thrilled by the fact
that americans are suffering and they
are excited they're not bothering to
hide it and they're excited because
finally
with no vote in congress they're going
to get their green new deal they're
going to get it by default now that you
can no longer afford to drive your car
or heat your house you're going to be
forced to switch to what they're calling
renewable energy
this is the biggest possible change out
with the old united states of america in
with the new the leaders think it's
pretty exciting as well as of course
highly lucrative for them and their
donors
but wait a second you may be wondering
can we trust these people to develop and
build an entirely new energy grid to run
western civilization do they actually
know anything about energy do they
understand how our current power grid
works can they fix a go-kart can they
operate a leaf blower do these people
have any skills at all apart from
running corporate hr departments and
giving ted talks
those are fair questions
to answer them you might consider what
has happened in europe since the neo
liberals seized control of the energy
grid there wall street journal piece
from last fall pretty much sums it up
quote
energy prices in europe hit records
after wind stops blowing that's the
headline
it turns out that windmills need wind in
order to produce electricity on a calm
day the blades stop turning and the
lights go out now you may have already
known that but the green energy people
were completely shocked to see it
it took a lot of people by surprise said
one economist quoted in the paper if
this were to happen in winter we've got
significantly higher demand then that
presents a real issue for system
stability
so clearly we have a significant design
flaw here but this is 2022 so it's
hardly insurmountable you can just trust
the science the most obvious solution is
to place enormous diesel-powered fans in
front of the windmills
that way wind farms will never be
without wind and we will never be
without electricity it's pretty clever
sandy cortez likes that idea but joe
biden is thinking bigger than that biden
plans to issue an executive order
commanding the wind to blow now we
already know that our elected officials
are in charge of the weather that's the
entire premise behind the green new deal
vote for us will change the weather so
why not take it one further step
americans want common sense weather
control
from now on per joe biden's order it
will be windy come on man we're bringing
that press conference live when he gives
it
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight